de nouveau roman d'olivier adam
s'intitule la renverse dans ce nouveau
roman on découvre un personnage qui
s'appelle antoine qui est libraire en
bretagne et qui semble avoir une vie en
tout cas une adolescence un peu
compliqué qui rend un peu difficile sa
relation aux femmes et en lisant le
journal un jour il découvre la mort d'un
homme politique qui l'a connu
visiblement il retourne dans la ville de
son enfance en banlieue parisienne dans
une banlieue pavillonnaire qui a l'air
plutôt calme où il n'a pas pu se passer
grand chose et on découvre que antoine a
quitté cette ville
lorsqu'un scandale politique a éclaté en
fait il s'est révélé que sa mère était
la maîtresse du maire et que tous les
deux ont été mouillés dans une sombre
histoire de violence et de manipulations
sexuels sur des jeunes femmes un petit
peu perdues voilà il a coupé tous les
ponts avec sa famille et va nous
raconter son enfance
ce qui ce qu'il a vécu ce qu'il a
ressenti la relation avec ses parents
aussi le père qui semblait tout ignoré
en tout cas vouloir tout oublier la mère
qui avait l'air innocente donc c'est pas
tellement enfin voila il va raconter
tout ce contexte ça peut résonner aux
oreilles de certains parce que ça fait
référence un scandale politique qui a
été révélée assez récemment
donc voilà olivier adam va raconter
toute cette ambiance on n'est plus du
tout dans ses histoires d'amour un peu
bancal comme il a pu faire dans ses
précédents romans
là on est vraiment sur un fait politique
est sur un fait social aujourd'hui je
vous présente golem de pierre assouline
qui est son dernier roman
c'est un roman qui se trouve à mi chemin
entre le roman policier le roman de
littérature donc l'intriguent la
principale intrigue se trouve dans
l'assassinât d'une femme qui se trouve
être la femme d'un maître d'échecs et
donc ça va être la fuite en avant de ce
maître d'échecs à travers la france puis
l'europe donc ce qui nous a plus
vraiment dans ce bouquin là c'est
surtout cette description tout ce voyage
dans l'europe de l'est où ils parcourent
pas mal de capital et il ya une vraie
être vraie belle écriture une vraie
profondeur dans le style et qui vraiment
nous promène et nous amène un peu à
découvrir tous et toutes ces capitales
de l'europe de l'est donc et en plus de
ça il ya cette fameuse intrigue où il
faut trouver le meurtrier lui et surtout
à la recherche du meurtrier de sa femme
et il cherche désespérément à trouver à
trouver la faille
donc il y a cette vision la deûle
intrigue et qui va découler d'une
société secrète sur le transhumanisme
donc il ya aussi cette vision là du
roman qui est un aspect finalement très
peu on entend très peu parler de ça et
ça aussi c'est aussi l'intérêt la de
d'avoir une vision du transhumanisme et
qu'est ce que finalement la technologie
va amener à l'homme dont je vous
présente le nouveau roman de jean
echenoz envoyé spécial aux éditions de
minuit qui est un vrai joyau est une
vraie pépite à lire c'est une opération
en fait un peu abracadabrante d'une un
pastiche en fait de film d'espionnage
un peu à la baisse à 117 où il essaye de
monter une opération de mission il leur
faut un pigeon si je puis dire ça va
tomber sur constance constance qui
s'ennuie un peu dans sa vie et qui va
prendre parce qu'avec kidnappé elle va
être voilà on va essayer de la forme et
pour une mission et qui va prendre ça un
peu comme des voix des vacances
inattendu et qui va partir yeux fermés
voilà c'est assez burlesque complètement
abracadabrant drôle les vraiment drôle
avec surtout un rythme endiablé avec des
rebondissements totalement inattendu
s'est intelligemment fait c'est pas
loufoque
c'est abracadabrant et rocambolesque
surtout intelligemment fait et surtout
avec un style absolument géniale qui
fait justement inscrits et d'autre le
fait qu'on soit vraiment mais en extase
devant ce bouquin moi j'ai eu un vrai
vrai coup de coeur c'est un vrai bonheur
à lire et le cas surtout c'est qu'il
nous met vraiment dans un régal total de
lecture voilà jean echenoz envoyé
spécial aux éditions de minuit donc le
nouveau roman d'edouard louis s'appelle
histoire de la violence on l'a connu
avec en finir avec les dix belles
gueules où il dénonçait la manière dont
il avait vécu son enfance et son
homosexualité dans le nord de la france
dans un livre un peu violent là il
reprend un titre un peu accrocheur mais
qui est bien plus subtil dans son
contenu
lors d'une soirée de noël en rentrant
chez lui il a été agressée et violée par
un homme qu'il avait rencontré dans la
rue donc il raconte cette agression
évidemment c'est un moment difficile
mais il raconte aussi toute la façon
dont il ressent les choses
la manière dont il recense et son dépôt
de plainte
au commissariat comment il va le
raconter à sa famille etc
il raconte aussi la vie de l'homme qui
l'a rencontré et qui la violait parce
qu'ils ont discuté un certain temps et
voilà il s'est un petit peu c'est une
relation un petit peu conflictuel parce
que à la fois cet homme là la trahit la
violenter et en même temps ils essayent
de lui trouver des excuses
c'est vraiment intéressant de d'essayer
de comprendre et edouard louis victimes
de ce violent et ce violeur qui
visiblement était plutôt quelqu'un
d'intelligent de d'attentionné qui a qui
a dérapé pour une raison qu'on a du mal
à comprendre